ladies and gentlemen counselors please
be upstanding for the chairman of the
council
I'm going to turn this on I've only done
this once or twice before uh the
Reverend Katie cross will say a few
words for our new Council today thank
you
well thank you very much for inviting me
and for having me over this past year to
begin each of our Council meetings with
a prayer and I'll do the same today
heavenly father as we recognize the
changing seasons the shift from one time
of the year to the next we acknowledge
that we can find change difficult
we can see the benefits of change all
around us but often when it confronts us
personally we can find it hard
we acknowledge too the opportunity and
excitement that change can bring
the new season in which to act when
different things are possible compared
to before
as this Council negotiates all that
change brings with new councilors
stepping forward and those who have
stepped back we give thanks for all the
good work accomplished by this Council
we bring to mind the highlights we give
thanks for those who've contributed to
the life of this District
and we pray for those who are picking up
the mantle praying that you would give
them wisdom and discernment in the
coming months so that the decisions they
make will be for the flourishing of our
communities
and so we lift the members of this
Council to you and The Business of this
meeting we pray for a productive meeting
the discussions will be effective and
decisions will be clear
we pray that important things will be
tackled with sensitivity and Grace
and we ask that you would give this
Council solutions that best meet the
needs and benefits those they serve in
the name of Jesus Christ amen
thank you thank you members would you be
seated please
now before Katie goes
I would like to thank you so much for
supporting me over this this year and
these are a small token of my
appreciation for you thank you very much
[Applause]
I would just like to have a crowded
chamber today and it's really absent to
see so many people here
um we have got obviously guests Friends
new members Etc I would just like to
welcome all the guests of uh Victoria
who's uh can be taking over shortly if
if you get the voted in and also we have
some of our past chair people here and
ex-counselors so I welcome them and it's
good to see you all again thank you very
much
all right
as members are aware I um this year's
being a chairman has a good opportunity
to do some fundraising for your
charities
um and I nominated this year the rnli
and those uh supporting those with
dementia
the rnli is a personal one to me I was
uh although living as far from the sea
as possible almost uh I served 11 years
in the Merchant Navy
and I also appreciate how difficult it
is to be at Sea it's probably in the
blood as well because my father and his
family were from fisher fisher folk in
in our growth
and I found out recently that actually
three of my forebears have drowned at
Sea in the fishing so we did actually a
quite a personal pertinent point to me
as well the sea has an attraction to
many
however people often get into trouble
and the rnli get called out to many
incidents each year as an example the
rnli launched their lifeboats over 9 000
times and saved 389 lies
in 2022
it shows you how important and valuable
the rnli as it touches so many families
through this as well
so I am really delighted to be able to
present a check to the local branch
Stratford branch of the rnli and Kathy
and your team would you like to come
forward please
check for 1500 pounds to the rli
[Applause]
ers
[Laughter]
men and women and for choosing our
charity
um we do appreciate it and this is
probably the easiest fifteen hundred
percent
um
it's very difficult but when James
people like you choose our charities
thank you
[Applause]
all right members and as it is a first
time for some of you and also our guests
a little bit of housekeeping if I may
can I ask that you either turn your
phones off or to silent
secondly we are not expecting a fire
alarm but if you do hear one please make
your way outside and congregating the
SDC car park at the rear
and this meetings being broadcast to the
many thousands of our viewers so welcome
everybody
um so here you can follow the
proceedings
right I would like to welcome you all to
this meeting welcome and congratulations
to those members either returning and
some familiar faces or those recently
elected I wish you all well
before we move into the agenda we are
losing three of our senior officers
uh with both both Dave Platt who joined
in 2016 and Phil Grafton on my left who
joined in 2013. David
they say that when you lose one senior
officer it's unfortunate but two it's
just careless
um I do wish Phil and Dave all the best
in whatever you're going to be doing in
the future so thank you for your support
and also I'm sure the council thanks you
too
I will return to the third person
shortly
now for one of my shortest meetings ever
in accordance with the council procedure
rules we need to elect a chairman for 23
24 in accordance with Section 3 and 4 of
The Local Government Act I now seek
nominations for the role of chairman of
the council for years 2023 2024
councilor Kate ruff
uh thank you chair
it is my absolute pleasure to propose
councilor Victoria orcock as chair of
Stratford on Avon District Council for
the year 2023-24
I have known Victoria a very long time
and in fact it was entirely my fault
Victoria's been involved in local
politics for all these years now
she has a wealth of experience in
chairing meetings and she is well versed
in Civic life having been met at
Stratford upon Avon
I look forward to you running efficient
meetings and I look forward to sharing a
part of your Civic life with you
therefore I propose councilor Victoria
orcock
thank you do I have a second to please
Council Jennifer
oh sorry
I should know how to do this it's not
difficult for you new members it's so
difficult
I'm delighted to Second the proposal for
councilor orcock to become chair of this
District Council thank you very much
indeed I have a proposed in a second are
there any other nominations
a certain pause of course but in
congratulations and Victoria you are now
a nominated chairman of Stratford
District Council for the years 2023
2024. congratulations
[Applause]
thank you
I Victoria Alcock having been elected to
the office of chairman of the Council of
the District of stratford-upon-avon
hereby declare that I take office upon
myself and will duly and Faithfully
fulfill the duties of it according to
the best of my judgment and ability
I undertake to be guided by
stratford-on-avon district council's
code of members conduct in the
performance of my functions in that
office today's date 24th of May 2023
oh
no thank you
[Applause]
all right
okay let me just sort my papers out then
they'll be with you
agenda
yes
[Laughter]
that was a mean trick
right
I do have a consort
I do have a consort because I couldn't
imagine doing this without him my
consort is my husband Gary orcock and if
I could invite him to come up
and accept his
his badge of
China consort thank you it is a chain
breaker
I can't reach I'm a bit short
right
hope you get used to wearing a chain
again
thank you for your support
[Applause]
okay
okay so item two on the agenda
devotive thanks to the retiring chairman
that the council offers its sincere
congratulations and thanks to Mark
Cargill for the exemplary manner in
which he carried out the duties of
chairman for the council in 2022-2023
um Mr cargo would you like to reply
thank you
thank you madam chairman and uh
congratulations I'm sure you'll have a
lovely year thank you
I mentioned earlier that I have two
Charities this year and I'm still
working on the final details of the
second one but I intend engaging
professional musicians to visit and
numerous dementia centers throughout the
district
and to entertain them music is a
well-recognized therapy helping reduce
anxiety and stress and also
improving speech of some people who have
dementia who perhaps have enclosed
within their their own little world
I also intend continuing fundraising and
I have hope to have the program of
events in by early next year
now I have an opportunity to thank those
who have helped me both over the last
year and particularly over the nine
years I've been a councilor
there are of course many but let me say
that you are genuinely now in one of the
best councils in the country and be
proud of that it is a good Council
that is in large part down to the skills
enthusiasm and commitment of its
officers a number of which are at the
back there and thank you all for that
their dedication is a credit to this
Council and I hope you'll maintain the
progresses council's made and take this
Council to new levels
the pandemic hit us hard some harder
than others financially though this
council is the fourth hardest hit in the
country but we came through without
having to cut Services a record not many
councils or all councils can claim that
was down to the fiscal responsibility
and the hard work that we're in the
sound position that's a team effort
again during the pandemic our officers
stepped up and supported us members in
helping our communities through that
difficult period so to all of the
members thank you very much sorry all
the officers sorry thank you very much
indeed
all right um you know politics can be a
little brutal and we have lost some
excellent hard-working counselors this
year it's important to remember that we
all become councilors to support our
communities and I wish them well in
their retirement
I cannot fail to thank our Democratic
Services team
for new members it will soon be able to
appreciate the amazing support you get
from them thank you guys and I really do
appreciate it now so including the Pas
and Democratic Services they've all
helped out now time for a few sea-based
puns David and Tony have captained the
Good Ship SDC with a steady hand on the
tiller
steering you can see some choppy Waters
and guiding us safely to Port
it's been tough three few years but
thank you very much indeed for your time
effort enthusiasm
for me my Chambers here has been quite
amazing it's been an honor to represent
the district and fly the flag for
Stratford
uh I've been to some quite fascinating
events and a couple stand out
the recreation of the battle of Egyptian
was quite surreal walking down even High
Street followed closely by Knights on
horses our midnights and on horses very
interesting at The Other Extreme it's
not often that the chairman gets
upstaged as an event but when I open the
Doggy Daycare Center
the dog
so of course it's a new rural business
so there you go of course you've had
many formal events including the
Platinum Jubilee
passing up Her Majesty of the queen
reading the proclamation for King
Charles III and of course the recent
coronation
have been honored to be representing
Stratford for that
now this has always been a well-mannered
chain but I have no doubt that that will
continue and Victoria will be able to
keep you under control
I wish it well in a role and it's a
small token victory for you
thank you
thank you very much
now for a few personal thank yous for
the excellent support I uh I received
this year I'd like to thank Ian green
for doing all the print work including
that lovely check he just did there
recently for me all was at the last
minute
uh and uh yeah so so it's been really
supportive now they say that behind
every successful man is an exhausted
woman
well I have two
first Claire has been my PA for the year
and I believe in your 17th is it 19th
chairman sorry apologize for that uh
Claire is also retiring today
uh the day job keeps her busy and I've
certainly done that but I know that also
now because I was invited to one of her
performances she's an excellent singer
and performer and thank you very much
indeed for that Claire I couldn't have
done it without you thank you
thank you
America
of course the other woman in my wife's
life this year does that sound
bad okay
was of course my wife Catherine
I'll try that one again shall I The
Other Woman No Okay this year was always
going to be a tough one
um because Catherine was until last week
mayor of Ulster uh we didn't really look
forward to having both mayor and chair
at the same time but we managed it and
we had a fascinating year did we not uh
we knew it was going to be busy but
thoroughly interesting and you can
certainly say we're going out on a high
it only remains for me to say
well done
good luck and I wish you all well over
the coming years
thank you
okay it's my duty now to present
and that's his past uh Chairman's badge
being presented already thank you very
much one less job for me thank you
moving on with the agenda
number three appointment of the vice
chairman of the council and according
with the council procedure rules to
point advise chairman of the council for
2023 2024 in accordance with Section 5
of The Local Government Act 1972.
I now seek nominations for the vice
chairman for 2023 2024.
can I have a nomination please proposer
please
chairman can I it would be my utter
pleasure to be able to propose councilor
Jenny fredgley to be the vice chairman
of this Council for the coming year
thank you very much councilor G Ned may
I have a second for that please
uh it's my pleasure to Second the
nomination
are there any further nominations
then
oh in a can we vote on that please
well no we don't need to there's only
one nomination okay
um councilor Friday congratulations if
you'd like to come forward
for your Vice chairman badge
[Applause]
congratulations
thank you
having been elected to the office of
Vice chairman of the Council of the
District of Stratford on Avon hereby
declare that I take the office upon
myself and will and will duly and
Faithfully fulfill the duties of it
according to the best of my judgment and
ability I undertake to be guided by
Stratford and even district council's
code of members conduct in the
performance of my functions in that
office dated the 24th of May 2023
foreign
[Applause]
and if I can just invite councilor Ian
flaggley who I'm guessing will be the
consort
um up to the Days please
thank you very much
[Applause]
right to move on to item four of the
agenda
to a voted thanks to retiring Vice
chairman
I would like that become
that the Council Office it's sincere
thanks to Jill Foreman for the exemplary
magnet where she carried out the duties
of Vice chairman of the council in
2022-2023
uh thanks to gel
[Applause]
thank you all right item five
um apologies about of absence in fact
the head of paid services to report the
list of apologies of absence please
thank you chairman um apologies you've
been received today from councilors
Harvey uh hence
Pemberton who may have a bit late uh
councilor shenton and councilor Stanley
thank you
thank you very much for that item six on
the agenda I need to close this
disclosures of Interest please
of items on the agenda
yes Miss Brooklyn
thank you chairman I have a personal
interest in the appointment that we
turned officer on the gender item 11 and
I'll be leaving the room for that item
thank you
hey thank you and
she's interested
right okay
we're moving on to item seven then
report of the returning officer through
note report a returning offset naming
the person selected as District
councilors on May the 4th
I'd like to welcome the new councilors
to the council if I can ask you to stand
when I read your name
councilor Coles
counselor coucher
counselor guest
councilor grocott
councilor hatch
counselor Harding
councilor Hamer armor sorry Joe
it was always going to happen at
councilor homes
councilor Johnson
cancer Keithley
councilor littlewood
councilor organ
counselor Ostrander
councilor pressure
councilor Parker
counselor pattingham
councilor petrovich
counselor rice
councilor scorer
councilor Skinner
Council and Stanley
thank you all the chairman moved that
the council pays on record it's thanks
to the following councils who were not
re-elected the council at the elections
held on 4th of May
uh Joe Barker Tony Dixon Jason fortick
Jill Foreman
Jackie Harris
Tony Jefferson Matt Jennings Danny
Kendall
Christopher kettle Peter Richards
and John Riley
thank you all
you may be seated
item 8 on the agenda to appoint a leader
of the council could I in accordance
with our constitution can I call for
nominations please for leader of the
council Council of Rock
thank you chairman I propose Susan junit
to be the leader of the council for the
coming year
thank you Council of rock can I have a
second there please
uh councilor Adam
thank you madam chairman I'm very happy
to second that proposal thank you very
much
thank you very much are there any other
nominations
right then I'll say congratulations
counselor Gene Ed would you like to
thank you
can I just say very very quickly
that this is a magnificent for me it's
but it's thank you not only to my team
of counselors but to everybody that took
part in these elections because
democracy is important
just one thing more if I might like to
say
I'd like to dedicate myself as leader
not only to everyone in the district
but to the memory of my late husband as
well and I aim to deliver for all of
them on what was in our Manifesto but in
memory of everybody else that's ever
served on this Council so thank you very
much
well that's the main part of the AGM
completed I'd like to
Choice oh sorry before we've just
progressed that there is the leader's
statement and this is the scheme of
Delegation for executive functions to
the cabinet and to members of the
cabinet it is has been delivered to you
so it's that you can see exactly who has
been been appointed thank you very much
thank you Susan as leader um
again I would like to invite my guests
who thank you all for attending today
obviously not having very long to
prepare for this role
um it meant that you all had very short
notice
to attend and I'm very grateful for my
family my friends who are like family
new friends old friends and mentor to be
here with me today
can I please invite you all to
um return to go to the room next door
where you'll be served tea coffee and
hopefully chocolate biscuits
you are allowed to dunk have no fear on
that and I will join you shortly thank
you
okay then we'll carry on item nine on
the agenda uh political balance and
member of committees
uh can we note the political balance
calculation for 23 24 please
and the committee composition for 23.24
will be out that it should be out on
your tables
counselor please note that chairman of
Vice chairman we're appointing the
meetings that immediately follow this
council meeting
um so can I ask you to agree on the
political balance calculation please
okay thank you very much
um number 10 on your agenda appointment
two outside bodies
um councilor Junaid as leader of the
council to propose a nominations for the
appointments please
I proposedly um the appointment to
outside bodies as is out laid out on
your table and I'll wait for that to be
confirmed thank you
can I have a second effort that please
we'll take them on block
um on the table a second there please
counselor pedigella thank you
thank you very much
um all agreed
like
moving swiftly up
oh okay Cup oh here's me going ahead
item 11 on your agenda counselors
appointment of the returning officer
electoral registration officer
to consider report that seeks approval
to appoint the statue roles of returning
officer electoral registration offer
officer I'd like to invite Council unit
as leader of the council to introduce
this report
and can I put it on it's on the table in
front of you uh the appointment of the
returning officer electoral registration
officer for this council with the
imminent departure of David Dolby
um David Buckland will be appointed as
the returning officer and electoral
registration officer as from the 1st of
June this year and then the monitoring
officer be authorized tremend the scheme
of the proper officer appointments which
Farms forms part of the Constitution
that is the appoint that is the isn't on
the table in front of you and that is
what we are will be taking a vote on
thank you
thank you leader can I call for a second
for that please
uh thank you councilor Rock
um are there any other members who wish
to speak on that matter
good are we all agreed in that
thank you very much
and item 12 on the agenda members
allowance scheme
oh sorry we need to invite yeah Mr
Buckland back there you are as he's
carrying your head with that you don't
mind me
good
thank you
item 12 on the agenda members allowance
scheme lump sum travel
um
to consider the lumps gun lump sum
travel payments for members in line with
the council members allowance scheme
within the council's Constitution I
invite councilor junid as leader of the
council to introduce this item
this item is just to consider the
classification because of the new
District Wards
um particularly some of the big two
member Awards over towards the other
side of the the east of the district
um the note the changes to the
reclassification as I've set out
appendix one for the purpose of making
lump sum mileage payments under the
members allowances scheme
um that is the proposal thank you
thank you leader could I have a second
after that proposal please thank you
Council of Rock
anybody else would like to speak on this
matter
oh very well then are we all in
agreement
yep thank you very much that is past
right well note that the chairman of
Vice chairman of the Committees will be
appointed immediately following the
closure of this meeting
the next meeting of council is on the
10th of July
uh 2023
I now finally
I now formally close this meeting
thank you
[Applause]
okay councilors congratulations that's
one out of the way we've got another
five to do now
um so what will be held now is a meeting
of each of the five committees auditing
standards employment overview and
scrutiny committee planning committee
and Regulatory committee what we need to
do and and ask if you're staying for
these meetings please
I will be calling your names of the the
membership of each of the Committees if
you could please stand for the duration
of that committee that clearly indicates
who can then participate in that
particular meeting because it's only the
members of that committee that can
actually elect the chair and vice chair
and set the start times for the meetings
for the coming year
so we do have a series of five meters
we're going to start with audit and
standards committee
genuinely if there's any questions now
for for from anybody we have had a
briefing for the Chairman's or proposed
chairman so I should say at this stage
um earlier on is has anybody got any
questions about how that will work
because we're in that period between
meetings at the moment I just want to
get this right
if not
chairman I'll move over to you for the
to the kickoff okay thank you
um
well we can start with Audits and
standards committee please
I call upon the chief executive to
report the names of those cancers
appointed to serve on the committee for
2023-24 only those councils called upon
are to partake please
sorry thank you chairman so if I could
ask the following members please to
stand uh councilor Bromwich
councilor Jenny franchley councilor
Joseph harmer
we have apologies from councilor Trevor
Harvey and councilor Peter hentry
seraphin councilor pageem please thank
you councilor Parker
councilor patagella
Council of rice
thank you councilors
we also have apologies from councilor
Stanley and councilor shenton
I being the chief detectively like sorry
can I have any nominations please for
the chairman of the audit and standards
committee
because eventually have a second
I would like to Second The Proposal
are there any further nominations for
the chairmanship of the committee
in the absence of any further
nominations congratulations
constellation now the chair of the
committee and will continue for the rest
of the meeting thank you
thank you
I would like to ask for nominations for
vice chairman of the audit and standards
committee
hi there I'd like to propose
for vice chairman
thank you and I will second that
proposal
are there any other nominations
okay I now need to invite proposals for
the start time of the next meeting which
will be on Monday the 24th of July
I'd like to propose 4 30 P.M
do we have a second
good
are we all agreed
I would actually I'd like to propose an
alternative time because I know I can't
make that time I'd like to pose two
o'clock in the afternoons
okay
in which case
for that proposal
if there's no second there
we're okay we'll we'll have to pick that
up outside then then Tony but but yeah
in the absence of a second uh the only
proposed nominated uh seconded proposal
is to start time of 4 30.
sorry okay
okay I think all that's left then is to
conclude this meeting
um and the date of the next meeting will
be Monday the 24th of July at 4 30. and
I declare this meeting closed
thank you
okay moving swiftly on to the employment
committee
if I can hand over to uh Mr Buckland
thank you chairman
um
we're getting used to this now aren't we
so if for the members of the employment
committee if you could please stand when
I call your name uh councilor Victoria
orcock councilor Ian franchley
councilor David Johnson
councilor Susan Junaid it's like Duncan
Parker
counselor Anne Parry
councilor Nigel Rock
we have apologies from councilor Ian
shenton at Council Sarah Wally hoggins
as well thank you
do I have any nominations for chairman
of the committee do you need I would
come in
try again
yeah it's coming I'd like to propose
that councilor Johnson be the chairman
of the committee thank you do I have a
second I would like to second that
please thank you councilor
are there any further nominations
in the absence of any further
nominations congratulations David
councilor Johnson you're now chair of
the committee thank you
could I ask for nominations for the
position of Vice chair of the employment
committee
uh it's my it's my pleasure to propose
Council Drew Ned to be Vice chairman
could I second that proposal please
I was second
are there any other nominations
enthusiastes Susan Junaid is the vice
chair of the employment committee
could I have
um proposals for the start time the next
meeting on the 27th of June
I proposed 10 o'clock
can I second that please
are there any other proposals I I will
second that
are there any other proposals
are we all agreed
I conclude next meeting will take place
on the 27th of June at 10 A.M
and the meeting is now closed
thank you very much
uh Mr Brooklyn
thank you chairman two down three to go
um this time could the members of the
overview in scrutiny committee please
stand we have counselor Andrew Crump
councilor Ian French Lee
councilor Joseph harmer councilor Thomas
Holmes
councilor David Johnson
councilor Stewart Keithley
councilor Malcolm littlewood
councilor Dave passenger
councilman Mike rice
councilor Kate Wolf and councilor Sarah
buddy hoggins
not a chairman about to expire
um
do I have any nominations for chair of
the overview and scrutiny committee
yes thank you I'd like to propose
councilor Crump as the chairman of the
overview and scrutiny committee I thank
you councilor Keithley do I have a
second there
I think Council Audi hoggins
I second the proposal for Andy Crump to
be chairman of this committee thank you
are there any further nominations
congratulations Council you can now
chair the committee thank you
thank you Mr Brooklyn
we now move on to item four of the
agenda which is appointment to Vice
chairman
do hardly have any nominations for vice
chairman of the committee please
I would like to put those Council
passing the response to you
thank you councilor Frazier and
sorry can I catch the rice thank you any
other nominations
no cancel that passing them you are now
appointed Vice chair of the committee
for the year 23 24.
item five is start time in the meetings
uh have a proposal to consider the start
time of the meetings for 23 24.
no I was proposing I will propose
10 am
can I have a second there please
councilor Johnson seconding
thank you
any of that start times
now it seems like 10 o'clock is is the
preferred option
so thank you very much our next meeting
will be on Friday the 2nd of June and
just to confirm it will be 10 o'clock
thank you I'll close the meeting
thank you very much counselor um moving
on to a planning committee Please Mr
Buckland
thank you chairman so if the members of
the planning committee can now please
stand when I call your name councilor
Lewis Adam
councilor David Curtis councilmania
Legend
councilor Bill Fleming
we have apologies from councilor Harvey
and Hunter serifin uh councilor Holmes
councilor Keithley
councilor Parry
councilor passing him
councilor Pemberton
and councilor Skinner
good morning could I have any
nominations please for the chairman of
the community councilor Eden
have you flashed your badge Neil
just give it a second
no his isn't working I don't know it is
okay
um I'd like to propose cancer Adam as
chairman of planning thank you is there
any seconder
yes chair
um
having been on planning committee with
councilor Adam I think he'll be
excellent chair and I'd like to second
that proposal thank you thank you are
there any further nominations
in the absence of any further
nominations congratulations Council Adam
you're now chair of the committee
thank you very much
um
can I ask for nominations for the first
vice chair please
uh yes thank you councilor Adam I'd like
to propose that the first chair be
counselor Eden first vice chairman B
counselor Adam
I'll suck at that proposal chair
thank you very much
um are there any other nominations
no well in that case uh we've got a
first vice chairman so um can I then ask
for nominations for the second Vice
chairman please
um I'd like to propose councilor Keith
Lee for second Vice chair
and I'll second that chair
good thank you very much
um then we've got our second Vice
chairman uh we're not changing the
timing because we've already gotten a an
issued agenda so was there any further
nominations oh sorry were there any
further nominations for the sacrifice
chairman
thank you Mr Buckland uh in that case we
do have a second Vice chairman um we're
not changing the timing of the meeting
so the next one will take place on the
25th of May at 6 p.m and the meeting's
now closed
okay thank you councilors
um we're now moving on to the regulatory
committee Please Mr Buckland
thank you chairman uh last but not least
regulatory services so if we could
please stand when I call your name again
uh councilor Liz Coles David Curtis
Hasler Jenny frenchly
councilor Lorraine grocott
councilor Roger Hardin
councilor Olivia hatch
councilor Chris Mills
councilor Susan Ostrander
or standard sorry uh councilor petrovich
we have apologies from councilor shenton
and councilor Sarah Wally hoggins
thank you do I have any nominations
please for chairman of
I'd like to propose councilor Jenny
fraggley as chairman
thank you do I have any seconder that
proposal
yes I'd be very happy to second that
proposal thank you do I have any further
nominations
in the absence of any further
nominations you're now chair of the
regulatory committee thank you
do I have a seconder
are there any other nominations
thank you
um so Council Harding is now Vice
chairman of the regulatory committee
can I ask now for nominations for the
three chairs of the licensing committee
I'd like to nominate councilors Curtis
Jenny fraggley and Coles
do I have a second for that proposal
yes I'm very happy to second that are
there any other nominations
those three councilors are confirmed as
joint chair
may I have a proposal for the uh
starting times and day of the meetings
please
I'd like to propose
um 3 P.M on Thursday the 22nd of June as
opposed to 10 a.m on 23rd of June as in
the council diary
may I have a second for that proposal
yes thank you I will second The Proposal
are there any further proposals
we have a further proposal thank you
I'd like to propose 10 a.m for licensing
on that day please
I'm sorry regulatory thank you
uh is there a second for that proposal
I was thinking that I'm chairman
okay in this instance because you've got
two proposals unless there's any it's a
third proposal
no in which case I suggest that you take
a vote firstly for those in favor of
start time at 3 P.M please may I have a
vote for those councilors in favor of a
3 P.M start
exactly may I have uh people the council
is against that proposal
two
has carried therefore the proposal is
carried for 3 P.M thank you
uh finally uh the uh the next meeting
will take place on Thursday the 22nd of
June at 3 pm and that all future
meetings will take place on the Thursday
and now this meeting is closed thank you
record time which I'm rather impressed
is
um all that leads me to say is they're a
teen coffee being served if you would
like to come
and join us I think
um
and thank you for making my first
meeting go quite easily
I declare this meeting
closed
[Applause]